je leur porte pas aussi un tous les
ministres une carte d'affaires caviardé
pour railler le gouvernement legault nos
révélations sur les entraves quant à
l'accès à l'information alimente les
critiques de l'opposition
on va utiliser des faux prétextes
données de la fausse information pour
bloquer l'accès à des documents trois
responsables de l'accès aux documents
explique la radio canada être l'objet de
pressions on dirait que tous les moyens
sont bons pour refuser l'accès à un
document explique une de ces sources qui
poursuit en disant c'est fou comme la
loi n'est plus respectée ces sources ont
voulu taire leur identité par peur de
représailles de plus radio canada a
appris qu'un mécanisme permet aux
établissements de se concerter avant de
répondre à une demande ce qui est
contraire à l'esprit de la loi en
commençant par assuré non pas
l'autonomie mais l'indépendance de ceux
et celles qui gèrent les demandes
d'accès il traite les gens je demande de
l'information comme des menaces pour que
la vraie menace c'est pas l'information
c'est pas la transparence la vraie
menace c'est la noirceur la sphère
provoque une petite tempête les jeudis
m'ont encore des règles les règles à
respecter le gouvernement nie les
allégations d'ingérence politique c'est
pas une intervention politique mais ce
sont les présidents et dirigeants des
six et des cieux s'entendent pas avec
certains de leurs employés ce qu'il faut
donner moi ce que je dis ou mais comme
message aux pdg de six essieux c'est
respecter la loi 62 tout ce qui peut
être donnée doit être donné c'est
plusieurs est-il qu'il faut quand même
moderniser les paramètres et elle laisse
une grande part de discrétion qui ne
permet pas de rendre des décisions
uniquement dans l'intérêt public le
ministre responsable éric caire veut lui
simplement augmenter la quantité de
données qui sont accessibles directement
sur internet à tous les citoyens ici
david gêne-t-il radio canada bon rien